[Musik]
guten abend in allen hier ist ein kurzes
nachrichten update von uns aus der heute
redaktion angriffe auf juden gibt es
jeden tag in deutschland meist sind es
beschimpfungen und beleidigungen immer
wieder geht es aber auch um körperliche
gewalt insgesamt gab es im corona jahr
2020 deutlich mehr antisemitische
vorfälle sagen die recherche stellen
antisemitismus das hat mit verschwörungs
erzählungen zu tun aber nicht nur marcus
groß alle starter celski wird regelmäßig
im netz antisemitisch angefeindet die
kommentare bei twitter und facebook
beleidigungen und beschimpfungen mit
anderen jüdischen studierenden engagiert
sie sich im internet und auf
veranstaltungen gegen antisemitismus und
israel hass nach der jüngsten eskalation
im nahost-konflikt hat die
judenfeindlichkeit zugenommen
mich hat es natürlich sehr mitgenommen
und da fragt man sich schon bin ich
sicher auf der straße trage ich
irgendwas an mir was auf ein jüdisches
zeichen hindeutet angst und
verunsicherung die recherche stelle
antisemitismus registriert solche und
andere vorfälle schmierereien
beschädigungen übergriffe vier
meldestellen gibt es bundesweit 2020
wurden dort für bayern berlin
brandenburg und schleswig-holstein 1437
vorfälle gemeldet fast 15 prozent mehr
als im vorjahr besonders an ticona demos
mit ihrem holocaust verharmlosungen
haben für einen anstieg der zahlen
gesorgt juden und jüdinnen wurden zum
sündenbock gemacht wurden entweder für
die verbreitung des virus die herkunft
des virus verantwortlich gemacht wurden
aber auch wissenschaftlerinnen oder
politikerinnen die sich mit der pandemie
beschäftigen mussten als jüdisch
markiert und so unter einfluss einer
geheim jüdischen gruppe dargestellt
antisemitismus sichtbar machen darum
geht es einer starre 6 key sie wünscht
sich mehr solidarität und mitgefühl der
nicht jüdischen gesellschaft und jetzt
in der sendung eine quarantäne regel der
deutschen behörden die jetzt viele pläne
für den sommerurlaub entscheidend
durchkreuzen könnte und zwar auch für
doppelt geimpfte nach england breitet
sich die delta variante vor allem in
portugal aus über die hälfte aller neuen
corona ansteckungen dort geht darauf
zurück deutschland stuft portugal
deswegen jetzt als so genanntes
virusvarianten gebiet ein
und das hat enorme folgen zurückkehrende
urlauber auch geimpfte und genesene
müssen ausnahmslos für zwei wochen in
quarantäne und bald könnte es weitere
reiseländer treffen thomas kunz
frankfurt flughafen die maschine kommt
aus portugal viele passagiere früher als
geplant ein yes reise ende fast eine
flucht aus faro porto und co denn ganz
portugal gilt als virusvarianten gebiet
delta breitet sich aus besonders in
lissabon der anteil der variante dort
gut 70 prozent und 7 tage incidents im
land 93 auf tour als insel madeira aber
nur 16
während an tirol in österreich wo
jeweils nur region eingestellt worden
sind und das jetzt ganz nordrhein
haftung genommen wird das ist für uns
unerklärlich überhaupt delta als reise
killer
das befürchtet die branche neben
portugal haben in europa auch österreich
und tschechien einen hohen anteil an der
variante außerdem spanien und italien
ein landwirt dann zum varianten gebiet
wenn es das ganze infektionsgeschehen
dominiert aber sollte nicht die zweifach
impfung freiheit geben das
gesundheitsministerium und virologen
verweisen auf eine erhöhte gefahr denn
es sei klar
selbst wenn ich mich doppelt geimpft
habe also ein vollständiges impfschema
habe dass wir es trotzdem mich anstecken
kann dass iris weitergeben kann das ist
mit der impfung nicht ausgeschlossen
denn noch unbeschwerter urlaub werde
wahrscheinlicher wenn weiter geimpft
wird auch sozusagen als brecher gegen
kommende virus wellen wenige tage nach
dem amoklauf von würzburg hat es heute
morgen in erfurt eine messerattacke
gegeben zwei männer erlitten
schnittwunden und musste operiert werden
inzwischen wurde ein verdächtiger in
seiner wohnung festgenommen ein 32
jähriger deutscher er war der polizei
wegen gewaltdelikten bekannt und gilt
als psychisch auffällig das motiv ist
noch völlig offen
die spannungen zwischen russland und der
ukraine könnten sich noch einmal
gefährlich verschärfen
der grund ein seemanöver im schwarzen
meer ukrainischer marine und die us navy
üben dort zusammen mit kriegsschiffen
aus mehr als 30 ländern
russland hat die gewässer rund um die
von ihr besetzte halbinsel krim zur
sperrzone erklärt
völkerrechtlich gehört die krim zur
ukraine
die deutsche bahn will rund 3,6
milliarden euro in den knotenpunkt
frankfurt am main investieren
das soll reisen quer durch deutschland
schneller machen über einen tunnel unter
der innenstadt sollen fernzüge in einen
neuen tiefbahnhof einfahren bis zu 1500
züge sollen den bahnhof täglich an
steuern allerdings fertig sein wird das
ganze frühestens 2040
es ist ein klassiker es soll der
achtelfinal kracher werden morgen abend
in wembley england gegen deutschland das
finale ist das ziel hören wir aus der
deutschen mannschaft heute bis zu 45.000
hauptsächlich englische fans werden ihr
team in london antreiben lars ruthemann
über den tag davor flughafen nürnberg
vor zweieinhalb stunden der dfb tross
macht sich auf den weg richtung london
kurz vor dem abflug trafen wir den
bundestrainer noch zu einem zdf exklusiv
interview
wir freuen uns darauf ich glaube
deutschland england
bei den turnieren da spricht man jahre
darüber und von daher sind wir glaube
ich bis in die haarspitzen motiviert
der dfb wollte das abschlusstraining
eigentlich im wembley stadion bestreiten
dies hatte die uefa aber erst sehr spät
und nur unter bestimmten auflagen
erlaubt glaube sonntag spätabends kann
dann die nachrichten könnten doch aber
dann wollten wir den plan jetzt nicht
mehr über den haufen werfen
da ich noch immer an der schädelprellung
aus dem ungarn spiel leidet wird morgen
sehr wahrscheinlich leon goretzka
beginnen
antonio rüdiger hat seine grippe
auskuriert und manuel neuer der machte
sich im abschlusstraining schon mal mit
dem typisch englischen schmuddelwetter
vertraut bleiben noch moment in london
nur das was aus dem süden der stadt
gemeldet wird hat mit fußball nichts zu
tun
in der nähe des bahnhofs elefanten
castle ist ein gewaltiges feuer
ausgebrochen
mehrere geschäfte und fahrzeuge brennen
es soll auch explosionen gegeben haben
die polizei geht nicht von einem
terroristischen hintergrund aus
dann schauen wir jetzt wie's wetter wird
aktuell warnt der deutsche wetterdienst
vor schweren gewittern in
nordrhein-westfalen in hessen
rheinland-pfalz und in baden-württemberg
morgen im nordosten und südosten länger
sonnig sonst viele schauer und gewitter
zum teil wieder unwetterartig mit
starkregen hagel und sturmböen
das ganze bei 20 bis 32 grad so viele
von uns in der kürze ich danke für ihr
interesse und wünschen einen angenehmen
fußballer